aujourd'hui avait lieu les assises du
handisport pour la première fois en
Indre-et-Loire un rendez-vous pour
parler de l'accès au sport pour les
personnes en situation de handicap
physique ou sensoriel en Indre-et-Loire
moins d'1% d'entre elles dispose d'une
licence sportive on en parle tout de
suite avec nos invités
bonjour Denis Gauthier bonjour Christine
vous êtes président du Comité Handisport
d'Indre-et-Loire
25 clubs sportifs du département adhère
à ce comité ça veut dire qu'il n'y a que
25 clubs en Indre-et-Loire qui proposent
des offres d'Handisport oui
effectivement il y a aujourd'hui une
grosse rupture d'égalité dans le domaine
de la pratique sportive pour les
personnes en situation de handicap il
faut savoir qu'en Indre-et-Loire il y a
24000 personnes en situation de handicap
et on atteint péniblement effectivement
1% de licencier quand on comparaison
avec le public 10 valides on compte 26%
de licenciés toutes discipline
confondues sans parler de ce même public
qui peut avoir accès aux salles
sportives ou au footing le matin donc on
est vraiment dans une rupture d'égalité
importante donc concrètement qu'est-ce
qui bloque cet accès au sport ce qui
bloque c'est aujourd'hui la
communication c'est à dire que les
personnes elles-mêmes en situation de
handicap méconnaissent véritablement le
rôle et les missions du mouvement
handisport et de manière générale quand
elles le connaisse aussi à la pratique
de haut niveau puisque effectivement
aujourd'hui dont on parle du handisport
c'est principalement dans le cadre de la
compétition et du haut niveau et en fait
elle se disent que c'est pas fait pour
elle alors qu'en fait leur disparu c'est
d'abord et avant tout l'accès à la
pratique de loisirs et après évidemment
la compétition aussi donc c'est vraiment
un gros problème un gros défaut de
communication et qui est important
aujourd'hui de recontextualiser aussi
donc c'est la communication mais ce
qu'il y a il y a une offre suffisante
non il y a évidemment c'est déjà la
communication parce que notre public
même ne se sent effectivement pas
forcément concernés et de manière
générale l'ensemble des acteurs aussi
qui sont dans le médical dans le champ
du médico-social et qui travaille auprès
de notre public mes connaissent
également notre notre rôle et notre
objectif donc si vous voulez finalement
tout ça joue plus que en notre défaveur
et concrètement qu'est-ce qu'on a besoin
en fait quand on veut quand on est une
personne en situation de handicap qu'on
veut faire un sport il y a des un axe
des modalités d'accès particulières dont
on a besoin qui sont pas présentes dans
tous les clubs non pas forcément ce
qu'on a besoin c'est déjà de
d'accompagnement et en tout cas d'avoir
un club en tout cas de faire le sport
qu'on a choisi et non pas d'aller au
club le plus proche de chez soi et
d'aller faire un sport par défaut
aujourd'hui on fait tous le sport qui
nous anime et ça doit être la même chose
aussi pour les personnes en situation de
handicap et en Indre-et-Loire d'ailleurs
on travaille un peu sur cet accès au
sport il y a une charte d'engagement qui
a été signée en 2022 entre plusieurs
collectivités et structures dans le
département en quoi consiste cette
charte et ce qu'elle a un effet déjà
donc c'est nous qui en sommes à
l'initiative effectivement et donc cet
après-midi se tenait les premières
Assises du handisport en fait c'est au
regard du constat que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure et des chiffres qui sont
particulièrement tragiques ou en fait on
s'est dit qu'on ne pouvait pas
travailler seul et qu'il fallait en fait
finalement associer l'ensemble des
forces vives de notre département et
travaille deux pair avec l'ensemble des
interlocuteurs qui ont un rôle à jouer
dans le développement du sport pour tous
et c'est dans ce contexte là que cet
après-midi s'est tenu les premières
assises qui aujourd'hui au travers de
cette charte on fait écho national
puisqu'il y avait donc la ministre qui
n'était pas présente physiquement mais
qui avait adressé un message vidéo et un
enregistrement et qui montre
effectivement que cette charte elle est
au-delà des du département 37 et qu'elle
va faire école dans l'ensemble du de la
France puisqu'en fait elle va chercher
l'ensemble des compétences des
différents acteurs que doivent et dans
le dans le département elle a un effet
déjà bien sûr on a en un an on a on a eu
une hausse de 20% de licencier donc en
fait on est passé de à peine 1% à
21% il y a en 12 mois on a on a plus que
doublé d'accord donc en fait les 1%
c'est plus l'actualité
donc ça a un effet
sur les 23 400 personnes en situation de
handicap
et bien merci d'Annie Gauthier merci
beaucoup